when Stage a nova série de sucesso da
Netflix inspirada na família Adams eu
acabei de ver há dois dias e adorei meu
eu fiquei super fascinado com a mãozinha
aquela mãozinha que anda por lá a
chamada de thing ou a coisa e eu tive a
Brilhante ideia de imprimi-la em 3D em
tamanho real e reparem só nesta
Maravilha pessoal a textura da mão da
pele está incrivelmente boa tem aqui
também os pontos das costuras têm as
unhas está incrível já está em escala
real também quando eu baixei a modelação
tinha aproximadamente 11 cm aqui agora
está com 20 está tipo o dobro Bora
Perpétuo print agora é partem com o meu
PC buga porque esta não está com muita
resolução 18 horas pessoal 18 horas e 40
minutos para imprimir esta mão
[Música]
vídeo 18 horas se passaram que na
verdade até foram 19 horas eu acho mas
aqui está a nossa impressão da coisa
reparem só pessoal está linda a nossa
mão impressa em 3D eu tava muito
preocupado com estes pequenos Sports
aqui mas está ok está muito bom aqui tem
algumas imperfeições mas eu depois vou
corrigir com esta massa meu Estou muito
orgulhoso desta impressão porque quem
percebe tem pressão 3D sabe que
normalmente não corre bem a primeira nem
à segunda nem a terceira foi impressa a
primeira tranquilamente correu tudo bem
Não gastei filamento perfeito
juro está num tamanho perfeito Quase que
eu consigo encaixar a mão aqui
em cima ficou bem podre Mas vamos
restaurar isto Ok como tinha aqui mas o
Sports deu bosta aqui em geral tá ótimo
e não sei quanto é sério
já avisei que vai dar merda isso
ficou bom
vem cá sai da escuridão
Tás a combinar com o vereador
posso abrir
sinceramente Ok Segura bem
um pouquinho mas eu vou restaurar isto
Tudo É que pessoal vou ser sincero eu
não estava a preparar assim tanto este
vídeo só tive a ideia e fiz então Eu vou
pintar com as tintas que tenho em casa
eu não comprei nada especializado eu sei
que muita gente pinta com aquelas
pistolas e tudo mais eu não tenho isso
em casa então vai no pincelo mesmo seja
o que tu quiser vai ficar muito bom pá
eu tive sim
não agora eu tenho vamos comer no doce
já tá com coisas
Bora lá lixar a parte de cima que ficou
uma bosta basicamente eu quero retirar o
excesso de filamento vamos ver o que é
que vai dar
agora vamos colocar esta com aplast que
também ajuda bastante a tapar os buracos
e todas as imperfeições e logo após isto
vamos voltar a lixar até ficar perfeito
aqui por dentro da mão também estava
horrível Então bora acoplada para cima
dela neste processo perdi quatro horas
da minha vida até que o acoplast secasse
até que descobri esta técnica
finalmente com o secador se ficou bem eu
tive aqui quatro horas à espera com o
secador demorei 1 Minuto aquilo que não
consegui fazer em quatro horas ya aqui
dá para ver mais ou menos os buracos com
a classe da Pou meu deu um trabalhão e
se há coisa que faz lixo é lixar a
acoplaste suja tudo agora sim depois de
dizer que ficou bem suave Bora lá então
a pintura ok aqui vamos dar uma primeira
mão primer só para dar aquela base mesmo
gostosa
Ok a primeira de mão secou e mesmo assim
eu não fiquei contente com o resultado
Porque ficaram muitas imperfeições então
eu tive que lixar voltar a colocar o
Acqua Place de esperar bastante horas
até secar voltar a lixar voltar a
colocar o acoplast Já vos disse que
voltei colocar lá com plaste logo tem a
colocar o acoplast que voltei a deixar
secar voltei a lixar deu muito trabalho
esta parte mas bora lá então finalmente
à segunda demão Aqui está a dar stream
com uma lata na mão
eu já perdi a conta dá quantas horas
estou neste projeto Mas neste momento
são quatro da manhã e acabamos aqui
todos os pormenores e a seguir vamos já
passar a pintura deixa-me só como ficou
aqui a nossa
aqui em cima eu consegui recuperar muito
bem eu acho que o meu ver tá muito bom
já Estas são as únicas que tem em casa
ok então vamos utilizar eu já digo aqui
testar vários tons de pele mas está
muito alaranjado ainda o mais próxima à
cor que eu quero vai ser esta mas mesmo
assim preciso de escurecer Ainda mais eu
tenho aqui algumas referências da cor Ok
mas vamos basear um pouco mais nesta
imagem eu estou a utilizar apenas as
cores primárias estou a usar o amarelo o
vermelho e o azul bem aqui estou eu bem
cansado depois de muitas horas a fazer
ali as correções Aqui estamos a juntar
algumas cores até chegar à cor de pele
que eu quero meu eu juntei laranja com
vermelho com branco com azul até chegar
ao tom de pele perfeito e mesmo assim
conseguir chegar ali num tom mais ou
menos alaranjado ok e eu decidi colocar
a tinta com uma esponja porque eu tentei
com o pincel e não estava a colar tão
bem a tinta então usei a esponja acho
que foi mais eficaz e depois Acabei por
usar um pouco mais o pincel né mas acho
que ficam um efeito Bacano ok aqui já
consegui chegar um tom de pele mais
escuro tou aqui a tentar fazer algumas
sombras e tudo mais só para não ficar
uma pele tão mata então ya tentativa
erro pincelar com as Esponja até
chegarmos a um tom de pele bacana
[Música]
e ficou mais ou menos assim eu acho que
tá bom não é pipo quero fazer acham
tenho ainda muitas horas pela frente
desejam sorte e deixem também o like
para ajudar aqui a divulgar o vídeo
pessoal bora Okay aqui já está a fazer
os pormenores com um pincel mais fino
como as unhas tentei fazer ali umas
sombras no nó dos dedos já estava ali
também a fazer as cicatrizes os metais e
tudo mais foi bem trabalhoso pessoal
Então tou ali bem tranquilaço da vir a
pintar o resultado final pessoal E vocês
comentem aí embaixo O que é que tão a
achar mais um dia se passou vamos
continuar o projeto Boras um como ficou
o estudo de graça aqui está paleta das
Tintas que eu usei tem muito lixo aqui
muitos textos de cor e bom quando eu
achei que estava tudo feito ainda decidi
dar mais uns pormenores ali nas zonas
metálicas dar ali um apontamento a mais
de sangue e fazer mais umas linhas ali
nas cicatrizes e ficou mais ou menos ai
não posso esquecer daí ali também com
verniz das Unhas só para dar aquele
destaque em relação à pele e ficou mais
ou menos assim
mais um projeto finalizado depois de 30
e tal horas de trabalho aqui temos o
nosso projeto completo pessoal a mão do
wended meu deu muito trabalho espero
mesmo que tenham curtido o resultado
final foram 30 e tal horas de trabalho é
impressão a pintura esperar secar
esperar imprimir tudo e mais alguma
coisa deu um trabalhão enorme pessoal
então enquanto mesmo com a vossa apoio
aqui no canal e isso ajuda-me imenso a
perceber se vocês querem ver mais vídeos
de impressão 3D aqui no canal Então é
isso pessoal não é o que mais o vosso
tempo Obrigadão Espero que tenham
gostado fiquem bem até ao próximo
[Música]